and then like every single page I'll
write
in the same color
what's the job of a movie director
that's a deep question
um
I think we've kind of talked about it
throughout this whole interview but but
um I mean it's working with actors it's
shot listing the script with the DP it's
really working with all of the
Departments and getting the best out of
everybody while moving towards an
overall vision of the film and then the
story and keeping the story intact
keeping the story you're trying to tell
both visually both both creatively and
on a deeper meaning you know in a deeper
sense all together as one and having the
actors be on board for that once you're
hired as a director
what are you looking for with the
screenplay like what's your process how
do you look at it I like to look for I
like scripts that have flawed characters
um that are that are trying to achieve
something great
um and I like scripts that have villains
that believe that they are
in the right
because I think that's interesting to
have those types of conversations with
actors and and dig into that and get
into that psychology of of well why does
this person believe that they're right
when they're obviously the bad guy right
so like you know everybody believes that
they're the hero of Their Own Story So
finding that mentality and having those
conversations where you might be talking
to the good guy the guy the actor who's
playing the good guy and you're like you
know you're completely justified in this
and that then you're talking the actor
that's playing the bad guy and go look
this is how you feel because this guy
has wronged you and blah blah blah so
like you getting into that psychology
that's interesting so I think I start
thinking of that but also like if I'm
reading a script and I don't start
seeing the movie when I'm reading it I
don't I I know I'm not connecting with
it like I have to read it and if I'm
reading it and I'm like I start seeing
shots that I want to do and like going
like oh wow this and this like if that's
not happening then like it just it just
means that I'm not connecting with it
interesting will you give it at least
another pass to see did I miss something
no you know yeah if I'm not connecting
with it there like it just means that
like you know it's it's just it's not
not connecting with the material like I
have to start seeing it and going oh
that would be fun to like if I find
myself going well how would I shoot that
like then it means I I want to shoot
that like that's like but if I'm looking
at that going like well that's stupid
and like going here like it doesn't you
know it means I'm not connecting with it
you know um
which is interesting because you know a
lot of the the script's really important
to me because like I was raised by a
writer and a lot of the scripts I did
early on in my career I I wrote myself
um and you know a lot of times I do
tweaks on the scripts that I'm directing
that I didn't write I'll tweak out
dialogue or I'll do like a little like
you know director's password type stuff
on my own but
I haven't really fully written scripts
anymore myself since my dad passed away
really it's been much harder to will
myself to to do that because a lot of
what was really fun about writing
scripts was being able to talk to him
about what I was writing and if I would
hit like some writer's block I'd call
him and he'd talk things out with me on
the phone and then I'd keep going uh so
it's you know it's definitely been hard
plus I was writing a script with him
right before he passed away and I didn't
finish it and I promised him I would and
so I still haven't done that so it feels
weird thinking about other stories until
that one's done
so I don't know at some point I'll write
something again
so James you brought some cool stuff
here you have some scripts yeah yeah so
I do like color-coded notes for each
department so uh and then I also here
I'll show you well look at the hot seat
one real quick
um so well this I have my shot list in
here as well but then what I do and I
draw like little overhead maps of like
where I want the blocking to be for each
like little location so you see like
little overhead things in here with with
now we're actually able to print out
like what the actual
overhead of the the
location is now which is pretty cool
um so I don't have to draw it by hand
fully but then I'll do like this so
it'll be like actor hair makeup art
props FX Camera lighting wardrobe and
then like every single page I'll write
in the same color of like what my
thoughts are for for each thing so I
it's every page of the whole script I
pre-direct all of it and kind of come up
with like thoughts and ideas throughout
all of it and then that was the most
recent one because apparently I didn't
discover until you know the last one
that I could have um
uh
Whatchamacallit
um a pens that were made in that color
so what I would do is just write it out
and then use a highlighter to highlight
it before and then I would put little
colored tabs on every single page and
where are the tabs the tabs would color
would correspond with the color coding
so I'd go okay if I see a green tab this
is when I'm in the with effects this is
what I got to talk to them about go to
the green tab Pages or like if I'm like
okay this is the yellow tab Pages or for
art go to all the yellow tab pages to
talk to them about that so it's you know
and then still see like look there's the
evolution look at the little little
overhead blocking maps that I was
drawing but I was having to draw the
location whereas over here
I was able to
oh
print out an overhead of the location
didn't have to draw it
I thought that was pretty cool very cool
but yes you know every page is color
coded with you know different notes for
every department and did you start doing
this from the beginning or was it
because
you knew that in the moment knowing this
certain color you could flip to it no
matter how much chaos was around you I
started doing that yeah it was from a
trial and error because I I you know so
much so often I'd be like I'd come on to
set and I'd be like you know I want to
tell you [ __ ] what was I talking about
I'll be right back and then I'd leave
right but what I what I started doing is
like Okay so this and I'd like talk to
them right so I you know I I I started I
started to write down notes for myself
so that if I forgot what I was trying to
say it would be there or if I was like
you know uh if I was jumbled up or
you're moving fast and like you know
because you call cut and you're like
okay well I got to talk to the DP about
this I got to talk to this actor about
this got attacked that actor about that
I gotta talk to this so you just refer
back to like okay well this is what we
were thinking great I have my notes it's
all in a thing great that's all stuff
that before even being in the moment I
told myself like a week ago that I
wanted to do so I'm like Okay cool so
that brings it back that brings us where
it is you're shooting a lot of the time
out of order too so it reminds you okay
this is what you felt was important
about this scene this is what was this
is the emotion you needed to get out of
this scene this is what needed to happen
with art for this scene that you felt
was really important right this is what
you needed the camera really do for this
scene that would get that emotion great
we're all there we're all in the same
place we understand it so it just brings
you back to what that goal was and it's
all stuff that you've gone over with the
actors with the DP with the production
designer with the costume designer with
the you know makeup artist before making
the movie you did that in pre-production
so it's it's just gently reminding
people of the conversations you've had
and and looking for stuff and and it's
just pre-planning for everything so you
have an eventuality of like maybe
something isn't there maybe the
chalkboard isn't there so you can go
okay that wasn't that important to me
this was so let's move to this next
piece of what this would be
how many group meetings do you usually
have before filming
um with who like each department each
department I mean you hopefully a lot
the more the better you know
um hopefully as many as possible
do you do a script read with all ever
like a table read with all the actors or
sometimes if you're lucky enough to have
all the actors available
um
but mostly you know because that's the
one thing that could be great to always
do that because sometimes people will
say something and on the day you're just
adjusting words because they're like
that doesn't really make as much sense
if this person's saying this or like you
know this this might on the page read
normal but like when somebody says it
you're like that's not how people talk
and it's not the fault of the actor's
performance it's the fault of the words
on the page so you want to change some
of the words because like you know
a perfect example is like maybe
somebody's saying I am very mad at you
because of this right and that's like
their line and it's like it seems like
cheesy but like you know it could easily
just be changed like ah [ __ ] off right
like uh go [ __ ] yourself or like or like
you know leave me alone right but it
gives you the same emotion that you
needed right so maybe you're just like
man they wouldn't be saying that they'd
say this in this moment right so then
you're changing it or maybe it's just as
simple as like you know
I'm I'm pissed at you because of yada
yada and you're just like chop that off
I'm pissed at you right get rid of the
yada yada you know so sometimes it just
you know
yeah message taken yeah
it's good
you're right because maybe it's too
formal and it's overwritten yeah it's
too stiff and somebody wouldn't say that
exactly but you sometimes it looks
normal on the page but you need to hear
people say it before you're like oh [ __ ]
that doesn't sound right what do you
think about directors though
that
they're so stiff with the script they
won't there's no you have to say the
line I can't have you deviate from it
that's not me I mean you know I think
that's I think I'm I'm a very strong
believer of like you know say the gist
of the line as long as like you say like
kind of what the intention of the line
was make it your own as long as it
doesn't throw off what the actor across
from you is doing
um and as long as they're aware of what
you're going to do you know that's how I
feel however you know like I always say
this like I also I'm a firm believer
like as far as wardrobe goes it's like I
might talk with a costume designer about
like what I want the actor to wear but
then I like to let the actor make their
decisions from there and let them do
everything and what they like and what
they don't like and and stuff and shape
it and I'm very very giving in that
sense towards the actor because I feel
personally that the Wardrobe that the
actor puts on is is the first thing they
do to become that character and so I
don't want to dictate if I've talked to
them about how we feel about the
character and we're on the same page I
don't want to dictate to them what they
what they they feel this person would be
wearing for their shoes if a certain
shoe is how they feel like is the
emotion of what this person is or like
you know the jacket that they wear
usually what I say is like it's more of
like a you know as long as you're not
coming in a clown costume I'm I'm
usually cool with what the person wants
to wear because I feel like I've talked
more in like emotion and color palette
and let them just kind of go from there